un texte la haute classe et remanié pour
nous payer archiver samouni siro mon
caddie la branche qui fait travailler
puis malet hôtel à céder mon client nie
pas ses 70 madame tiny 80 l'année et
donc donc à fait libre à la pour faire
mieux comprendre qu'il faut cette vie
donc là poursuivi ben au boulot ni la
connaissance la connaissance de tout
bateau l'école annie graphie particulier
basé pratiquement sur la phonétique et
qu' il ya une faune au logis a donné une
leçon de la et donc il faut écrire ce
sont là alors au départ les gens ont été
très rigoureux sur le son et tout ça
avec des eagles w et d'ailleurs ça
paniquer la population les gens et ça a
poussé déjà et c'est pour cette raison
qu'on voit qu'on n'a pas été tellement
est cuit
donc nous avons sept ans de tolérance eu
des mots sur des maux qui sont confolens
en français des mots où il ya beaucoup
de variantes puisque rien n'est cuit a
pas vraiment un dictionnaire c'est vrai
il ya plusieurs dictionnaires mais c'est
vrai mais la population s'est pas encore
approprié tout ces dictionnaires là pour
bien née que les mots bien connaître les
mots et cette pause nous avons certains
trolls et rassure ses tournées grammaire
même sur des éléments de la graphie
c'est important aujourd'hui que c'est
les deux langues cohabiter et non
se fassent la guerre mais non les deux
ans qu à 8c même papa et maman jamais
mme fatima et puisque nous pouvons dire
que nous avons la langue française
langue standard la langue du nord de la
loire de paris nous avons nous à nous la
langue créole et on voit bien que
n'ayant pas bien fait la différence
entre l'anc et la langue française la
propreté à l'école il ya un mélange qui
se fait maintenant nous savons qu'il ya
le mélange est alors benabidi français
réalisé que francisé puis lundi internet
et puis l'américain bill burton di meo
lect c'est-à-dire village de famille
français régional que nous avons ou par
exemple à cette fille-là coin du feu et
tout ça est ce que c'est du français
est-ce que c'est lui que nous sommes au
milieu
fatima my mais le travail que nous
voulons faire maintenant c'est bien par
les lames en clair et bien et que à
20.16